Oh,
Trump got a lot of criticism for saying they were going to pull troops out of
Syria.
Yup.
And when,
when you see,
you know,
the debate about that or actions possible actions against North Korea and all
this kind of stuff,
like how do you,
do you,
do you view this,
I mean obviously you view this as a guy who has served,
it's been overseas,
but do you,
do you look at things like these are potential issues that are coming up and
things you need to be concerned with
the Syria and,
well the Syria one,
there are guys from the community over there.
They've been actively engaged.
Iraq,
it's funny,
the news reported for a long time.
We've withdrawn from Iraq,
all US troops out of Iraq.
No they weren't.
We've always had a presence there since we invaded in 2003 so [inaudible] and I
can go
tit for tat on a lot of issues where the news gets it wrong,
which is why I don't necessarily look at it for me to inform my opinion.
Uh,
serious.
Certainly any area where
we allow a place for the,
and the only word I have for it is evil to grow.
It's going to happen.
The problem with the strategy that I see it is,
is that actually you.
So we started in Afghanistan,
and again,
this is my opinion,
not the military opinion.
I can only speak for myself.
We went into Afghanistan,
we were incredibly effective.
So we cut the head off of that snake,
but it spawned two more.
Uh,
you go into Iraq,
you can argue whether or not we were effective,
but then all of a sudden we started seeing foreign fighters coming in from all
of these different countries and the tactics that we started seeing used in
Iraq,
like my first deployment to Afghanistan in 2003 now 2002,
uh,
it was not uncommon to drive around in vehicles that were not ballistic.
They were not a resistant to mines.
It would just Tacoma a thin skin to combo that bolt would zip right through.
Fast forward to Afghanistan in 2008 and they're starting to see vehicles being
detonated by bombs that we first saw in Iraq that were coming across the border
into Syria where they were had the ability to allow,
again,
for lack of a better term,
that evil to grow,
to learn to come across the border,
to engage American forces,
then to flee into a sovereign nation.
We couldn't do anything about.
Then we started seeing that in Afghanistan,
but we got effective anytime that these people would get together and have a
large group,
we'd get effective at either capturing them or killing them so they realize they
need to be disaggregated.
So now we've spread this.
I think the last stat that I saw was isis is in 64 countries and the problem
that I see with the u s military is that we're very,
very good at going in and cutting the head off of the snake,
but we're not good at creating and holding infrastructure and the timeline
required to hold that infrastructure is well beyond the Palette.
I think of most Americans,
and the best example I can point to is South Korea.
We still have basis with an American presence in South Korea.
That war ended decades ago.
We still have basis in Germany.
We have basis in Italy now.
We're not necessarily using it for the same purposes,
but if we really want to control that area,
we have to be prepared to stay there for that long.
And I don't think the u s military one has enough personnel to do that and I
don't think the American populace has the Palette to allow that to happen.
Do you think that that's necessary in order to protect people from whether
whether it's isis or whatever comes after isis?
I mean,
yeah,
obviously isis is fairly recent,
right?
Al Qaeda,
Isis and they chat.
Yeah,
the Isol and all that.
Yep.
Whatever could be next.
Yeah.
So you,
you feel like we have to maintain presence in that part of the world,
period.
I think we should use the military as a measure of last resort.
I think that war should be a measure of absolutely last resort.
And I would love to see us evolve to a point where we use it less and less and
less.
Um,
I describe it as you're standing at a dam and you can see it,
a little spout coming out.
Do you put your finger in the spout knowing that it's not going to fix the
problem,
but it was going to buy you time to hopefully have somebody come and fix the
damn right.
That's the option I would go for versus just leaving it as it is and allowing it
to continue to weaken the dam or another sprout and come out my theory that the
military is really well served to provide that space,
to put that finger in that sprout.
So yes,
I think if we find an area where these ideologies are thriving,
we have to do what is necessary to remove that ideology and hopefully destroy
it.
Not,
not resettle it somewhere else,
but actually destroyed.
So yes,
the short answer is absolutely.
If we find areas where we can squash this down,
we have to go.
But I just hope that there's people smarter than me that had a much longer term
strategy because all we're doing,
in my opinion,
is the finger in the dam.
And is there a longer term strategy,
like when you see all the global conflicts?
I mean,
is there a time that we get,
I mean it's,
it's,
it sounds insane to say that there's never going to be a time where there's no
war.
It sounds like an insane thing to say.
I don't know if there's ever been a time,
at least globally,
not that the u s was involved,
but I don't know if there's ever been a time where there hasn't been worth,
I don't think their house,
I don't think there can be because,
and I,
I think we talked about this the first day I met you.
There's x people and there's white people.
Yeah.
They're not going to get along.
It doesn't matter what your belief is.
You have an access somewhere that has another belief.
And if you go to the extreme end of that belief,
that individual may be willing to take action against you,
violent action against you for your belief.
And there's,
I don't think there's a way around that because humans are just too diverse,
but is it possible that one day we'll move past this?
I mean,
is there any plans at all to try to facilitate some sort of a peaceful world
civilization where you know,
all nations kind of get along and some sort of a mutually agreeable?
I mean,
does anybody
have some sort of hundred year plan?
Isn't that hilarious that,
that's a funny thing to say.
I mean,
they didn't brief me on it if it exists,
but isn't that fucked though?
I mean,
human beings are always going to shoot until each other.
We're always going to have war.
Isn't that fucked?
Since the inception of human beings,
it seems like at least at some level,
and it thankfully it's microscopic in comparison to the overall total,
right?
But it's happening.
I think it's happened since man has been walking on earth and the only way that
we feel today that we can protect ourselves is to have the more dominant,
more powerful military and to make sure that we're the ones who get to dictate
whether or not evil flourishes.
Yeah,
I mean that's,
I would want a maybe a,
I want the,
the dominant ability of our military to continue to grow,
but I'd like to see,
and I think it's already moving this direction,
smaller,
more surgical uses of it.
I just,
the military in my opinion,
is not good at building infrastructure and holding terrain for a long period of
time.
It's just not what we're designed to do.
Right.
It's not the design of the military for that matter.
What,
what is the overall view about getting out of Syria?
It probably depends on the people that you ask.
What about people that you talk to?
Both sides of the coin.
I will get answers from.
I think we're making a difference to,
we're wasting our time
and I got that on the initial invasion of Iraq,
the initial invasion of Afghanistan.
There is one of the things that I enjoyed about the community I came from is
that critical thinking was it's rewarded.
It's not,
there's no attempt and people think about this,
you know,
you watched full metal jacket,
choke yourself with my hand and you get told what to do and how to do it,
how much time you have to do it.
People think that critical thinking has no place in the military.
But where I came from,
that's what we're looking for is people who are able to critically think.
So there would be,
we would have political arguments,
religious arguments,
philosophical arguments in the team room and then come together and go do
exactly what it is that our nation expected us to do.
So you're going to get both.
You get,
there are people who are conservative and Liberal,
Republican and Democrat and everything in between.
So I wish I could give you a,
like a very precise answer,
but I have heard every spectrum of answer from this is awesome to,
this is stupid.
I've,
you know what confuses me?
I've heard different opinions on the sod,
whether Assad is evil,
whether he's gassed his,
his citizens or whether or not he's a victim of propaganda,
some mass smear campaign like Whoa,
this is way past my pay grade.
I've heard the same thing and it's beyond mine as well too.
It's frustrating cause you know when you don't know whether or not this is some
propaganda or this is a real threat or whether you know he or whether it's
something like the Saddam Hussein's situation where yes,
he was an evil dictator but also removing him.
Mike create a power vacuum like Libya had a power vacuum.
Yup.
Kadafi with Libya.
I mean Libya is a horrific example of that,
right?
Yeah.
And I don't,
I don't know the longterm solution to those problems.
It's like I said,
I,
I spend enough of my waking hours truly questioning whether or not anything that
I was involved in made my family or your family or Jamie's family safer did.
I did,
I did my actions.
You road what the rest of the world thinks about the United States of America,
and I mean,
I,
I flew back and forth.
I think it had an impact in the moment.
I think it had an impact stopping the water coming out of the dam.
I think it was essential that it needed to be done,
but I don't know if any of that has an impact beyond that,
that time period that it occurred.